[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio more
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español más de 35 millones de
franceses acudieron a las urnas el 10 de
abril para elegir los dos finalistas de
la elección presidencial francesa
emmanuelle macrón actual presidente y
candidato a su propia sucesión y la
representante de la extrema derecha
marín depend obtuvieron 27 823 1% de los
votos respectivamente este próximo 24 de
abril conoceremos cuál de los dos será
el que gobernará francias los próximos
cinco años jean-luc mélenchon
representante de la francia insumisa
obtuvo casi 8 millones de votos
colocándose así en el tercer lugar del
podio
un factor que lo hace juzgar como pieza
clave en las elecciones del próximo 24
de abril para hablar de ese resultado de
cómo puede jugar el factor de la unión y
de cuáles pueden ser las consecuencias
en las elecciones legislativas francesas
de junio próximo saludamos aquí en
nuestros estudios a javier carbón y el
enseñante del instituto de ciencias
políticas de parís y egresado de la
london school económicos bienvenida a
esta escala en parís
javier carbón y muchas gracias por
invitarme un placer tenerlo con usted
con nosotros pero hay una cuestión que
llama la atención al fin conocerse los
resultados de la primera vuelta
electoral el domingo pasado la blume
lanzone inmediatamente hizo una
declaración a cuatro llamadas dijo no
hay que votar ni un solo voto por marine
lepén puede ser seguido este llamado de
atención del candidato no sé pues puede
ser seguido y es lo que está intentando
de hecho hoy día se está dando lugar la
consulta entre los simpatizantes de la
francia en su misa en la que hay tres
opciones para ver qué van a hacer la
segunda vuelta la primera opción es el
voto en blanco la segunda opción es la
abstención y la tercera opción es macrón
lepén no aparece en ningún momento entre
estas tres opciones en general por lo
que vemos de las encuestas vemos que la
frente en su misa está dividida entre
tres tercios el primer tercio alrededor
del 35 por ciento se está pensando en
votar macrón el otro tercio está pensado
abstenerse y un tercio está pensando en
votar al epen pero recordemos que en
2017 alrededor de estas fechas es decir
al principio de las dos semanas de
campaña de la segunda vuelta este
porcentaje estaba alrededor de un 20% un
20% de los sectores de me leen son
pensaban o querían votar al epen y al
final el resultado final fue sólo de un
7% es decir casi nada muy pocos votantes
deben eso acabaron votando por repente
en 2017 ven eso espera que esto suceda
de nuevo en estas elecciones pero lo
tienen mucho más complicado que hace
cinco años desde este sentido hay que
recordar que el candidato de la francia
insumisa llegó en primer lugar en una
serie de ciudades claves de francia
ciudades donde con una fuerte presencia
urbana por ejemplo en toulouse lille
estrasburgo montpellier down etcétera
como puede jugar esto precisamente en
las elecciones del 24 de abril no es
raro que la francia en su misa tenga tan
buenos resultados en zonas urbanas
porque tiene una coalición electoral
bastante curiosa la francia y sumisa
tiene votantes sobre todo de clases más
populares de un obrero digamos clásico
de corte industrial tiene un tipo de
votante más juvenil más educado más de
corte estudiantil que le atrae sobre
todo la posición de manson sobre el
ecología el feminismo solo
anticapitalismo sobre entera sismo y
tiene electorado de corte más inmigrante
de cierto origen inmigrante y estos tres
tipos de lectorados se suelen concentrar
en las ciudades el problema es que este
tipo de electorado es también el que
está más fuera del sistema político más
foral sistema económico y el que suele
abstenerse más desde hecho sabemos que
las ciudades suelen ser las que más se
abstienen en las en las elecciones y por
tanto esto puede jugar en contra de
mccomb porque tiene que movilizar un
electorado que está más desapegado de la
política justamente decíamos menor son
dice ni un voto para marín depende eso
no supone que la gente va a votar por
macrón como usted lo señala y además
ciertamente por esta franja de la
juventud donde él llegó en primer lugar
menores son obtuvo que hace treinta y
tantos por ciento de los votos vienen de
ese sector de la población es gente que
no se identifica ni con mccoy ni con ep
pero que al final de cuentas puede jugar
precisamente encontrar el presidente
saliente exacto sea el problema la
juventud es muy parecido a lo que le
pasa a macro con las clases populares y
es que son personas o su segmento de la
población que en francia está fuera del
sistema económico y fuera del sistema
político el grado de precaria por
ejemplo que entre los jóvenes es
enormemente alto un 20 por ciento de los
jóvenes están desempleados por ejemplo y
este es un votante pero además de macrón
ha mencionado muchas veces las bajas
tasas de desempleo que hay en general en
francia que es las menores de los
últimos 15 años esto es cierto pero
tenemos que acostumbrarnos a dejar de
mirar estos índices macroeconómicos como
que sean tan importantes porque porque
el problema actualmente no es que no
haya trabajo si no es que no hay buenos
trabajos y esto afecta especialmente a
los trabajadores más jóvenes que tienen
muchos trabajos precarios o muchos son
incluso trabajadores pobres es decir son
trabajo son trabajadores pero son pobres
en este sentido creo que hay un dato que
es más interesante que es la edad a la
que los jóvenes obtienen su primer
trabajo estable que no bueno simplemente
estable que es a los 27 años es decir
grande claro es decir son bastante es
bastante tarde en la carrera laboral de
los jóvenes y por tanto macro
necesitaría aplicar toda una serie de
medidas de políticas de izquierda para
atraer a este electorado y al de momento
no lo ha hecho lo que hay ha sido dar
entrevistas a medios de corte más
juvenil como el gran continuado wood ha
hecho videos con youtubers y twitter
pero en realidad los jóvenes no
responden a este tipo de políticas los
jóvenes no quieren que se les hable a
través de tuits quieren que se les hable
a través de las leyes a través o
decretos detrás de las políticas para
prevenir en este caso la precaria
juvenil y justamente a partir de eso qué
es lo que podría llevar a un joven a
decidirse el 24 de abril a ir a la urna
y depositar un voto en favor de macri
pues seguramente el electorado de mel en
sión que más votos de macrón sean
precisamente este electorado porque es
un electorado que está muy ideologizado
es decir le importa mucho en la cuestión
ecológica le importa mucho la costa en
el feminismo le encuesta le importa
mucho la cuestión del anti racismo y de
la xenofobia y en ese sentido le pen
representan lo contrario con su política
anti migración con su política xenófoba
representan lo contrario a lo que estos
votantes
quieren a nivel de valores y a nivel de
ideología
macrón en ese sentido ha jugado mucho
con el cuento de pedro y el lobo decir
de que viene el lobo que viene luego que
viene luego de la extrema derecha el
problema es que muchos jóvenes se han
dado cuenta de que bueno pues pedrosa
les ha mentido demasiadas veces y
entonces no está claro cuánto segmento
de este electorado va a acabar
movilizándose a favor de macrón y cuánto
va a acabar en la abstención es un buen
ejemplo esto de pedro y el lobo ahora
dicho eso la pregunta sería de cualquier
manera hasta un 20 por ciento de la
gente que votó por melón son dicen estar
dispuestos eventualmente a depositar su
voto en favor de marín que puede definir
precisamente que ese domingo 24 la gente
vaya y deposite el voto por ella pues
sobre todo lo va a definir la campaña de
macrón en mi opinión porque creo que
este es un voto el que iría al epen
desde melón show que es el voto más de
clase popular el voto más de corte
populista es decir un voto con
las élites con el sistema
político con el establishment
que hay actualmente y este es el voto
que diría seguramente no a las políticas
liberales de macrón no a las políticas
migratorias el giro a la derecha a
macrón
devoto
por su lado y antiinmigración y por su
lado xenófobo sino por su lado social en
lepe en el domingo por ejemplo de las
elecciones vimos como hablaba de
recuperar el estado protector vimos como
hablaba de la solidaridad la solidaridad
con los más desfavorecidos como hablaba
de luchar contra los poderes financieros
eso no significa que sus políticas luego
vayan a ser así porque realmente lo que
sabemos de los de las localidades y las
regiones donde gobierna el frente
nacional es que no mejoran
sustancialmente la vida de las personas
de las clases populares pero sí que es
cierto que a nivel retórico lepén se ha
situado en este polo social de una
manera en la que macro no ese polo
social javier carbonell sería por
ejemplo hemos hablado en los jóvenes
pero hay que recordar que 25 por ciento
de profesiones de profesiones
intermedias 25 por ciento de ejecutivos
votaron precisamente por melanson y ese
es el sector que podría eventualmente no
la juventud sino ese sector que puede
inclinar su voto en favor de pp si la
verdad es que hay una cosa que es
importante entender y es que a veces le
damos demasiada importancia
clases profesionales a la hora de
explicar el voto los votos y las
coaliciones electorales actualmente los
partidos son muy diversas por ejemplo
por dar un dato el 20 por ciento de los
obreros que votan lo hacen por macro no
lo que parecería contradictorio digamos
a primera vista en ese sentido creo que
hay otras variables como es la renta
como es la edad como es el nivel
educativo que creo que marcan más
actualmente el voto que las clases
profesionales yo creo que en principio
sería más bien el voto de clase más baja
y el voto clase popular el que se iría
al epen en mayor medida que el voto de
las clases más acomodadas porque estas
clases acomodadas ya en niveles en el
elemento cultural están más cerca de
macrón que del epp en una de las cosas
que llama la atención es que el
candidato menores son obtuvo en varias
ciudades donde apostaban o donde
gobiernan candidatos de los verdes de
los ecologistas obtuvo el primer lugar
notablemente y con una diferencia
bastante considerable sabiendo que el
candidato los verdes no logró ni
siquiera el 5 por ciento de esos votos
quiere decir que melones son ha hecho un
discurso mucho más inteligible mucho más
convincente ecológica que lo que hizo el
candidato del partido verde si la verdad
es que se produce una paradoja muy
interesante con el votante ecologista y
es que las encuestas nos muestran que
cuanto más cuanto más ideologizado uno
está hacia el elemento ecológico es
decir cuanto más le preocupa a uno el
elemento ecológico más se vota por menso
que por lado y por qué es esto y es
porque estos electores combinan y la
cuestión ecológica con otras cuestiones
me explico digamos que tú estás muy
preocupado por la cuestión ecológica
entonces es muy fácil que te acabes
preocupando por el sistema de producción
capitalista y es muy fácil que te acabes
preocupando por las cuestiones de género
y el feminismo y que te acabes
preocupando por las cuestiones del
racismo y la xenofobia es decir estos
electores combinan todas estas luchas en
una y un programa como el de mel en son
es ofrece un román mucho más coherente
en todos estos ámbitos que lo que hace
el legado que ella dio recordemos es un
político de corte más liberal se acerca
más al partido liberal alemán de lo que
representa a melson que es un ecologismo
más social y de hecho en su programa
actual dice esto explícitamente que es
necesario vincular los elementos
ecológicos con los elementos de la
crítica al capitalismo es decir sería un
candidato más soluble si se puede usar
el término una cuestión javier carbonell
y alumno de opciones que se puede decir
a progresar aún más rápidamente en las
elecciones en el 2011 obtuvo apenas 11
por ciento de la votación después subió
al 19 por ciento estamos llegando al 22
por ciento esto puede ser capitalizado
por su organización la francia insumisa
en las elecciones legislativas que
llegan el próximo mes de junio ésta es
desde luego la gran pregunta en general
cómo está montado el sistema de elección
en un francés diríamos que no porque en
general lo que está hecho es que las
elecciones de las elecciones de el
parlamento suelen seguir mucho las
elecciones presidenciales es decir el
presidente suele ir con un gran impulso
a las elecciones legislativas y suele
llevarse la mayoría esto es lo que pasó
con macrón por ejemplo cuando ganó las
elecciones con un partido que acaba de
montar un año antes y luego se llevó las
legislativas
pero este caso la cosa es distinta y la
cosa cambia porque la izquierda ha
aumentado un tanto por ciento su voto
con respecto a 2017 y la gran pregunta
entonces para llevar a macro a disculpa
para llevar al menso a la victoria sería
la coalición que se vaya a montar entre
los 200 partidos de izquierda y lo que
sabemos de otros de otras de otros
países y dos elecciones es que los
partidos se unen no cuando están mal
sino cuando tiene expectativas de ganar
inmenso tiene expectativas de ganar en
ese sentido su estrategia del domingo de
vender su derrota como una gran victoria
es parte de este impulso a favor de que
se logra una coalición de izquierdas
para poder lograr una cohabitación con
comadrón pues vamos a ver este próximo
domingo 24 cuál de los dos candidatos
finalistas es el que proceda es el
próximo presidente de los franceses y
sobre todo cómo va a jugar el voto que
obtuvo el candidato menos yo estamos
llegando ya al final de esta escala en
parís no me queda sino agradecer a
xavier carbonell enseñante del instituto
de ciencias políticas de parís y
egresado de la london school of
economics su presencia sus explicaciones
gracias por habernos acompañado abierto
muchas gracias por haber mitad de
ustedes les damos una nueva cita aquí la
próxima semana en otra escala en parís
[Música]
i